so
hey everyone and welcome to another hd
tutorial and this one's going to be on
audacity um audacity is a freeware
application for editing your video or
not your videos but for audio only this
is an audio editing freeware program um
and i just want to do a brief tutorial
for you guys on how to download and
install it as i'll be doing more
tutorials hopefully on like cool tricks
that you can do with it so this is the
first part of the video series on
audacity and i hope you like this
tutorial as well as the other videos to
come so thanks for watching subscribe
peace
all right welcome to my desktop here i'm
going to show you guys exactly how and
where to get audacity first of all we're
going to open up a web browser i'm just
going to use safari for the purpose of
this tutorial because it is the fastest
web browser that i have right now
so um
right now we're going to go to the top
and just go to any major search engine
maybe google shiny search whatever you
want then i'm going to type in audacity
and i'll do you guys the favor of
putting this link right here audacity
audacitydebts.sourcefitforge.com
in the description so this is actually
the audacity website very basic very
simple and you can see right here at the
top there is a download tab where you
can actually download the freeware
itself so i'm just going to click on
that and i'll i'll give you guys this
exact uh link right here so that you
guys can
just
pause the video and get in the
description and you'll be able to
download it as quickly as possible so
here there are two versions of audacity
the first one is a stable version 1.2
which is remember recommended for all
users it's the most complete version but
it's not the latest version and they
have it again for windows for mac os 10
and for linux then we have the windows
and mac os 10 linux version for the beta
1.3 version for the purpose of this
tutorial i'm going to download the
windows version 1.2 because i'm not
going to go into the beta this is going
to be the simplest download so what they
give you right here is the installer
and all you have to do is click on the
installer it'll say your operating
system right here since i clicked on the
windows button so i'm going to click on
audacity 1.2.6 installer it's going to
be a exe file so it's going to take you
to sourceforge and you have to pick
which one what you want to do with the
application i'm going to hit open so
that it actually actually opens the dot
exe installer so first it's going to
download it and then it's going to open
so i'll come back to you guys hopefully
when this um when this is done oh it's
already done downloading so on in order
to run it just hit the run button and
it'll start up the installer and if uac
does pop up if user account control pops
up just hit allow or continue for
everything so i'm just going to exit out
of the web browser in the background
here
and here we have the audacity setup so
this is going to install audacity 1.2.6
which is currently the latest version
however if you're watching this video it
might be a later version out now but
same instructions apply so just click
next i'm going to accept the license
agreement hit next
and this will tell you all about the
lead developers and all the credits
they're giving about the software hit
next for that and this is the directly
directory in which it will install again
hit next and i'm going to create a
desktop icon and associate audacity
project files
just hit next and install so this is
going to be a quick little installation
process not a very large program but as
you can see it's already finished
installing i'm going to leave the button
check that says launch audacity and
finish
now it's um beginning to launch audacity
we're going to hit okay because it's the
first running of audacity so it needs uh
language
all right this is what it will look like
when you've opened audacity this is the
audacity interface here with the buttons
on the top now i'm not going to go too
far into it because it is for a later
tutorial on actually how to use audacity
but this is audacity you do have it now
i'm just going to show you quickly how
to put the audacity icon which is shown
here in your rocket dock right here so
i'm going to choose a section to put it
in i'll put it right in my tool section
so i'm just going to first of all unlock
the rocket dock
then i'm going to take the icon and drag
it down here into the place that i want
it
right after right before sony vegas just
drop it down there
then what we're going to do is delete
the icon from the desktop because we no
longer need that and we're going to lock
up the system tray again or the rocket
dock again and we are done so that was a
brief tutorial on how to download
install and now you officially have
audacity you know you can open up
whenever you want and that was it so i
hope you enjoyed this tutorial and
thanks for watching this one and if you
have any other tutorial ideas or
requests just go ahead and subscribe and
send me a message and i'll get to it so
thanks for watching this one peace